welcome back to new rock stars i'm erik
voss and this is a breakdown of marvel's
moon night episode one as we meet our
hero grappling with dissociative
identity disorder and one of those
identities possessed by an egyptian moon
deity which gives us all a new cover
story for when we obliterate our friends
bathrooms i swear it was conscious [ __ ]
in the tub as we always do here at new
rockstars we're gonna break this down in
depth because unlike other mcu titles
moon knight is less about the marvel
easter eggs than it is truly impressive
cinematic details that make this series
a fascinating mystery and character
exploration also our merch partners have
dropped new moon knight inspired hoodies
and shirts a cool looking new latest
obsession design and when you get one of
those you'll get the added option to
write in a custom shout out that will
appear on screen in our moon night after
shows so get your hands on one of those
at
newrockstarsmerch.com the episode opens
not with the hero but with the villain
arthur harrow tattooed on his arm our
scales head in the mouths of crocodiles
those croc heads also on the head of a
staff for the egyptian deity he serves
emmett a funeral figure associated with
judgment seen with the head of a
crocodile front legs of a lion in the
hindquarters of a hippopotamus the
egyptians believe that when you die the
god of the dead anubis weighs your heart
on scales against the weight of a
feather and if it weighs more you're fed
to emmet amit was not worshipped as a
god per se but feared by egyptians as
the devourer of the dead dooming them if
they didn't adhere to the principle of
ma'at which referred to a way of life
that pursued truth and balance and
justice philosophically there's actually
a lot in common here with thanos another
mcu villain with a religious zeal to
cull all of life by half but whereas
thanos saw fairness in randomness harrow
and his disciples believe that one soul
should be judged on its merits past
present and future at least you can
imagine in a post-thanos society once
fate being determined by a bit more
order is the cult mentality kool-aid
flavor more folks would like the taste
of in his ritual he shatters a glass and
then puts the broken pieces in his
sandals walking on them with bare feet
now walking on broken glass is a real
world meditative practice but harrow
hides this inside his shoes spending the
whole day enduring great pain but
telling no one this tells us that he is
not doing this for show he is a true
believer the music we hear is bob
dylan's every grain of sand one of
dylan's 80's spiritual tracks recorded
after he found jesus became born again
christian kind of like how arthur harrow
sees himself as a reborn evangelist
every grain of sand refers to how dylan
saw the master's hand in every tiny
particle of nature and for hero in every
person he sees emmett's judgment that
could be another reason he walks on this
broken glass with every step he
pulverizes this glass back into grains
of sand because that's what glass is
it's it's sand when it's super heated
the marvel studios title card has been
updated so that now our new friends the
eternals can be seen on the inside of
the r behind rocket and by the way they
put rocket back where peter parker was
in the no way home title card because
peter can only appear in live action
titles that sony approves of and by
approves of i mean get some money to pay
for their poopy vampire movies and
suddenly the music changes from bob
dylan to anglebert humberdinks a man
without love which is about a man who
wakes up every day realizing he's alone
the first one actually juxtaposes
stephen's inability to remember his past
love layla and the third line reflects
how moonlight now shows him the way via
his new soulmate one that he is not yet
aware of konshu the egyptian moon deity
and we made steven grant now in the
comics steven grant is actually the
second identity of mark spector mark is
really the main figure the badass
mercenary that we start with and steven
is a new identity he adopts that of an
elite billionaire but i assume this
series changed steve into this awkward
museum employee to avoid the batman
bruce wayne comparisons because when
moon knight first came out in the marvel
comics a lot of people consider him
marvel's batman now behind steven's bed
as he awakes are a number of texts on
world history and architecture ancient
egypt etc these books hovering over his
head as he sleeps reflects how his
dreams or what he thinks are his dreams
take him back to that world now in the
foreground you can see his rubik's cube
completed which is interesting because
while trying to stay awake steven
intentionally fiddles with it and tosses
it never finishing it suggesting that
when the mark identity takes over he
might go ahead and solve the rubik's
cube we see how he strapped his leg to
the bed and surrounded himself with sand
all as a kind of sleepwalking security
measure but his first real step forward
of the day is his bare foot on sand
which the camera lingers on showing he
is more connected to the sands of egypt
than harrow whose first step of his day
is on larger chunks of glass his
goldfish gus is only one working fin
like nemo a comparison the pet store
owner later invokes but with one working
fin this poor guy is literally swimming
in circles just like steven is and you
see at the bottom of the fish tank is
lined with a pyramid king tut's head an
egyptian obelisk and a sunken boat he
talks to his mother on the phone
probably talking to no one hello mom
it's me
just checking in um i got your postcard
putting it up on gus's tank now now
assuming steven's mother doesn't really
exist is he sending himself these
postcards is mark sending them to steven
to help keep him in that dormant routine
later on in the gift shop we do see a
rack of postcards so perhaps this is
where he's getting the postcards that he
is mailing to himself he says goodbye to
his mom by saying anyways it's cheap mum
i'll try again tomorrow later gators
yes crocodiles are different from
alligators we talked about this in loki
but it will be later that he faces this
taxonomic order of reptiles but also
this all poses the question if stephen
grant is just another identity of mark
spector who does steven think he's
talking on the phone to is he just
leaving voicemails with a random number
is there a voice in box that mark
specter set up to help stephen along
with this charade it's just interesting
how all of steven's closest
relationships are people who cannot talk
back to him like the street performer
crawley now behind that bus is a
building marked atlantis island maybe
not to marvel's atlantis home of namor
or maybe just another building called
atlantis they actually shot all the
london exteriors in budapest so later
when we see what's supposed to be
london's national museum of art the
architecture is actually that of
budapest's museum of fine arts they use
vfx to swap out the hungarian for
english and this museum is first shown
in the reflection of a puddle that
steven steps through reflections and
mirrored surfaces are recurring motif in
this series all a way of showing how
steven connects with his other
identities stephen catches a girl
stuffing her gum in a mini pyramid of
giza it's not like there's anything in
there
yeah
maybe not
but
in there
something wicked a lie for shadowing in
two ways of course the wicked jackal
that steven will flee in this museum
later but also trailer footage suggests
that steven or mark will explore the
great pyramids of giza and they might
find something inside of them also
something wicked is a quote from
shakespeare's macbeth the witches who
say boy the cricket of my tombs
something wicked this way comes in the
play the witches are foreseen a monster
of their own making macbeth just like
how for steven the hero of this story
the monster is currently inside of him
he explains the egyptian burial ritual
and how their hearts were judged and the
girl responds with and did it suck for
you getting rejected from the field of
reads what if that makes sense because
i'm not dead am i stevie
yeah i love that second am i that oscar
isaac sneaks in showing how this girl
triggered his recent lapses with reality
even now he doesn't know if he's alive
or dead also weird question for that
girl to ask i don't dress that good
later while doing inventory with donna
he hands her the stuffed hippos then
moves to a box containing the stuffed
lions and the stuffed crocodiles
together these three are the anatomical
components of emmett he points to a flaw
on the poster the aniad you know what
the super group of egyptian gods you
know you've got horus osiris tefnut shoe
there's been a major blunder because
they've got seven gods here and leonard
has nine now he is correct that the
idiot of egyptian mythology has nine
members the sun god atom his children
shu and tefnit their children geb and
nut and then their children osiris isis
and set and nephthys and sometimes the
idiot includes horus son of osiris and
isis but this poster also lists hathor
the sky goddess who is not usually
listed among the iniad despite being a
very important deity who we should note
mates with konshu the moon deity to
enable creation but based on promo
material we will likely see the nine
members of the eniad and their human
avatars later this season stephen chats
with his gold painted street performer
listed in the credits as crawley now in
the comics bertrand crawley is a
homeless man in new york who serves as
an informant to moon knight he walks
around posing as a british aristocrat we
get another awesome puddle mirror here
as steven says goodbye to crawley what
we initially think is right side up is
actually upside down when a leaf drops
on the puddle on the top half of the
frame as steven tries to stay awake in
his textbook there's a mention of the
great rift god's turn away from man
which feels like it's setting up this
show's mythology with konshu and the
nine anyad members relationship to
mankind we're essentially adding a new
layer to the mcu plan of implying all
gods of human society from the history
we know are interwoven with the marvel
mythology as we saw with the asgardian's
connections with norse mythology and the
eternal's connections with all other
forms of mythology we have yet to see
how the christian religion ties into all
of that but my friends mephisto is
coming but if this textbook is supposed
to be showing the familial lineage of
the inead even if it's going youngest to
oldest it does seem a bit out of order
it's just a bit odd to list osiris first
whatever order you would go in but
remember all of this is through the eyes
of stephen who's certainly knowledgeable
about egyptian mythology but he does
have an unstable mind he is an
unreliable narrator a point of view
character through whom we are not seeing
objective reality necessarily so who
knows how much of this presented reality
is actually real and how much of it is
gonna be revealed as a fantasy at some
point he tosses up his rubik's cube and
he suddenly finds himself face down job
dislocated in the hills beside an alpine
village this is actually shot in
slovenia so apparently when stephen fell
asleep mark spector took over went to
the alps to steal the scarab from this
castle then left out the window and
steven woke up on the ground a voice
speaks to him go back to sleep worm yes
this is f murray abraham as konju
interesting that he calls steven the
worm as is steven is the invasive
critter that does not belong inside the
mind konchu of course the egyptian moon
deity possessed mark spector choosing
him as his avatar giving mark's
supernatural powers but he has less
control over mark's steven identity in
his pocket he finds a golden scarab with
egyptian hieroglyphics you can actually
see a closer look at these in the
closing credits of the episode we did
our best to translate these but they do
contain a mix of known alphabet symbols
and then other unknown ones the right
and the left halves of the scarab are
mirrored so if you look at the dividing
line in the middle and go to the column
to the right of that at the top of that
that is a read which translates to
either an e or an i beside a seated
figure beneath that there's a scarab
shape then the open mouth that's an r
then another eye beside a different
seated figure then a pair of figures the
column to the right of that is topped
with the quail chick that represents the
u or the w followed by another eye
beneath that the vulture that's an a and
then a figure i don't recognize that
looks like either a boat maybe an oil
lamp and then the horned viper that
represents f and then another figure
it'll recognize i'm gonna keep working
on this folks but all you egyptologists
out there hit me up this series has been
described as indiana jones beats fight
club and already you're seeing the
parallels there of course especially
indiana joe's last crusade which had a
whole set piece in a germanic castle but
by sticking with one man's point of view
his consciousness suddenly switched into
a totally different context is something
that we've seen actually in christopher
nolan's memento which is also told in a
non-linear narrative structure that
reflected the mind the protagonist who
suffered from short-term memory loss it
resulted in him finding himself in
intense moments with no knowledge of how
he got there similarly the fx series
legion which actually follows the marvel
mutant of david holler also explores the
intersection of superpowers with mental
health struggles and leaves the viewer
never quite sure what is real or not now
we've been talking a lot about ancient
egyptian artifacts and tombs that teach
us a lot about how people lived
thousands of years ago well right now
today we bury a ton of electronics and
landfills that will only teach future
generations that we didn't really
understand the real nastiness of e-waste
when you throw electronics away they
become e-waste which represents almost
70 percent of the global toxic waste
output a great way to keep toxic e-waste
out of landfills is by purchasing
renewed electronics and our friends at
backmarket have built an amazing
marketplace that offers expertly renewed
smartphones laptops and other tech for a
fraction of the normal cost i've been
addicted to this awesome 2020 rose gold
ipad air that i got from back market and
i love it it looks brand new it costs
way less than buy new and it didn't turn
into e-waste that's a pretty great
tablet folks and look at me now i get to
play my my bird games on it i'm living
my best life here helping this planet
live its best life in my own small way
and every purchase comes with a one year
warranty 30 days to change your mind and
free standard shipping plus with
backmarket's new back program you can
also sell your old tech for cash buying
a refurbished smartphone prevents 175
pounds of carbon emissions that's an
oscar isaac of saved carbon emissions i
think he's a short guy so use the code
rockstar and save twenty dollars on your
first purchase of expertly renewed tech
break up with new tech and find your
next device at backmarket.com
that's back market and not black market
and thanks again to backmark for
sponsoring this video interesting how in
the scene all the shooters speak to each
other in english what are you doing is
heading for the village just a little
indicator that these men in their
matching clothes are likely not native
to this alpine town but rather like many
cults in the real world move to these
places that just kind of like take the
town over with their interesting
vegetation outfits steven pulls a
harrison ford fugitive maneuver by
joining the procession with some
headgear to blend in in this case it's
his white hoodie white being the color
of moon knight's wardrobe arthur harrow
parts the crowd showing his long blown
out hair now harrow in the comics is
really a one-off villain from one issue
in 1985 a guy with a half-paralyzed face
carrying out some nazi experiments in
mexico really i think this guy's gonna
have a deeper identity that gets
revealed later in the series ethan hawke
said his version of the character is
based on david koresh leader of the
christian cult the branch davidians in
waco texas one follower submits himself
for judgment i judge you in amit's name
with but a fraction of her power the
tattoo scales sync with the swinging of
the staff which turned green to signal a
balanced soul meanwhile the old woman
the tattoo turns red with one scale
having a larger pile weighing it down
i've been good my entire life i believe
you but the scales see everything
perhaps it's something that lies ahead
and so he drains her life force leaving
her skin gray so anna judges her by the
sins she will commit in the future and
unless this is all [ __ ] and let's be
honest it might be this would be another
example of destiny existing in the mcu
something described in various ways by
the ancient one and he who remains in
loki like the tva pruning young sylvie
this woman is being punished for future
violations both of these systems of
justice cruelly denying the possibility
of a multiverse where people can make
infinitely different choices konshu
refuses to let steven hand over the
scarab kudos to oscar isaac for his
physical work here the way he can
divorce his head and his facial
expressions from the rest of his body
and then when he marches away from hero
he takes these big dramatic steps
similar to the big strides the towering
concho himself would take as they pry
the scarab from him stephen flickers in
and out of consciousness coming too with
blood on his face and fist just that
amount of blood on the scarab in his
palm is some of the gruesomeness we've
ever seen the mcu get as it implies he
may have had to rip off a few fingers to
get that scarab out of their hands he
flees in a cupcake delivery van that
plays wham's wake me up another cry for
help as steven wishes to be woken up
from this nightmare the fact that this
is playing on the radio maybe just a bit
of an ironic joke or just like an
interesting coincidence that one might
see in a dream steven grant wakes up for
this thinking it's a dream but as we
find out later it's not a dream so why
did such an ironic song play during it
then i just love how this show blurs the
lines for what seems real and what seems
fantasy as he struggles against his
pursuers he flashes forward again and
now find the gun in his hand the
windshield blown out that gunshot
shattered the side window and one of
those pursuing cars flipping i love how
this whole scene plays out like a
classic car chase with one person
steering one person shooting but with
one man doing everything and only seeing
half of it think how terrifying that
would be a logging truck overturns and
he swerves around it two more trucks
wedge around him and then mark takes
over again
yeah i like how on the transition out of
it you hear the gunshot as if the
gunshot is what woke steven up the
gunshot that probably shot the driver of
that sedan but before the logs crush him
steven wakes up he thinks back home
presumably mark was able to get out of
that somehow made his way back to the uk
back into the apartment back into bed
and the shopper behind proves this
showing stephen with reflections on
either side of him proving his truly
split identity yet his leg harness the
sand ring the door tape all seemingly
undisturbed but think about it if it was
another identity taking over not him
sleepwalking mark would have been fully
capable of avoiding the sand replacing
the tape himself it's a huge pile of
crumbled tape in that trash can i highly
doubt steven counted all the watts but
gus now has a second fully functioning
fin as indicated by the pet store clerk
mark during that last period must have
replaced the goldfish kind of like
parents who replace kids goldfish when
the fish die and they hope the kids
don't notice steven realizes he misses
date at the steak restaurant because
it's sunday not friday i'll have a steak
please
sure
what cut would you like
i'll have the best bit of the
mistake that's the bit that i want
center cups fill it um and how do you
like that good yeah very good very good
yeah
well done okay
delicious
oh for anyone who eats steak this is
painful to watch you never cook a filet
to be well done you're ruining it i'd
rather eat poodle [ __ ] but obviously
steven is a vegan and mark was the meat
eater who picked this steakhouse to
begin with he finds some scratches on
his apartment floor for where the table
was dragged over to access the hidden
crawl space and on the cell phone that
he finds all the calls are to layla
except one listing to comp jean paul
decomp is a mercenary an ex-french
foreign legion officer who is a partner
to mark spectre in the comics mark's
voice speaks to him and he sees the
reflection of the bathroom mirror
shaking his head when steven hadn't done
so he flees the elevator which stops
mysteriously on an empty third floor and
then again on the second where konshu
lurches toward him from the end of the
hall terrifying horror imagery here as
in the comics concho has a big skull and
a crescent moon staff and his limbs are
wrapped in linen like a mummy though i
like how his tail wrappings seem to
float as if detached from gravity just
amazing character design here contour
grabbing the lyft door turns it into an
elderly woman but even that doesn't make
total sense think about it because if
she was at the other end of the hall she
would be nowhere near the summoning
button and despite this elevator
previously headed down from the second
floor it's now back up on the fifth
floor where his elderly neighbor is
visiting her friend claire and we saw
steven repeatedly hit the button for the
ground floor it should not have gone
back up to the fifth now sure this may
just be the building's electrical
problems that stephen alluded to or
maybe khan shoes screwing with him but
really i think another example of how
basic things in steven's reality are not
abiding by normal logic steven turns
around and see konju right behind him i
love this close-up because you can see
all the texturing and indentations on
conscious skull like the little hairs
wafting out for the back of it but now
when we whip pan to steven's reaction
he's back on the bus meaning from the
fifth floor to now mark must have been
in control we see konshu standing on the
street but he disappears when the lamp
post crosses frame on his bus steven
realizes as he hops off harrow was on
that bus so either mark was pursuing or
more likely being pursued by arthur
herrera before steven regained control
harrowing his followers corner stephen
at the museum that um had been free
she would have prevented hitler and the
destruction he wrote
nero the armenian genocide pol pot while
eluding the history's worst crimes
against humanity harrow invokes the baby
hitler thought experiment what if hitler
could have been prevented from becoming
the mass murdering dictator something
deadpool 2 addresses head on harrow goes
on to say that she was betrayed was she
by indolent fellow gods oh
by even her own avatar avatars
blue people love that film by avatar you
mean that i mean anime yeah steven
references both james cameron's avatar
and avatar the last airbender but also
setting up the mystery of who emmett's
original avatar was and why they
betrayed him it perhaps influences from
the eternals or maybe pharaoh rama tut
aka kang the conqueror who also judges
people by their futures when harrow
tries to assess steven's soul emmett's
scales never settle this chaos in you
that's because steven has a completely
different moral alignment than mark does
and the destiny of this total individual
is really a complete variable depending
on whoever is taking control now would
that mean that anyone with dissociative
identity disorder that harrow assessed
would get the same results maybe but i
really think stephen and mark's
condition is amplified by conscious
possession making him uniquely
impossible to judge that night as the
museum closes the crescent moon glimmers
overhead foretelling this as the night
moon night will finally rise steven
passes his reflections and the two
others remain in the glass mark turning
back to see what is stalking steven in
this case the jackal that moves in the
foreground a jackal released by arthur
harrow to recover the scarab in another
shot steven is perfectly framed behind a
half-broken bust just a really cool way
of showing how he is sharing his mind
with one of these ancient figures the
jackal appears again behind statues its
eyes glowing super creepy steven flees
into the largest and nicest public
museum bathroom i've ever seen steven i
could save us
but i can't have you fighting me this
time
you need to give me control you
understand what control of what you're
talking about
that thing's about to break through the
door i love how for all of this we stay
in one take transitioning through whip
pants but staying in steven's point of
view at first the mark reflection turns
to face him while all the other infinite
steven reflections match steven's
movement but after steven turns to look
at the door and then back to mark now
only the mark reflection is there in the
mirror so there may be other infinite
identities in this mind but mark has the
full attention right now and then the
music cuts out as he says
you're not gonna die
let me save us and so steven finally
looks directly at mark into his eyes and
the transformation begins though notice
while the mummy wrappings envelop our
mark steven in the mirror reflections on
the side nothing is happening again from
the standpoint of objective reality it's
hard to really know how much of this is
truly real flickering on the bathroom
walls are glowing hieroglyphics and then
we cut to outside the bathroom initially
hearing the scuffle but then sink
crashes against the wall and the jackal
tries to flee but moon knight drags him
back in water pouring down from the
broken sinks giving us another mirrored
surface to reflect this character from
below he turns to us glowing white eyes
from behind the mummy wrappings in a
hood with a crescent moon sigil in a
beaked tip of that hood evoking the
skull of khonshu suspended in his chest
in those mummy wrappings is his crescent
moon weapon our final image of the
episode leaves us with moon knight's
eyes glowing white like the moon the
color white is important to moon knight
described amazingly in charlie houston's
2006 comics i don't wear white to hide
myself i wear it so they'll see me
coming so they'll know who it is cause
when they see white it doesn't matter
how good a target i am their hands shake
so bad they couldn't hit the moon i just
love how this sequence began with our
fear for the glowing eyes of the jackal
and it ends with the jackal being afraid
of its prey taking on the glowing
terrifying eyes of the hunter again
check out our awesome moon night merch
over at new rockstarsmerch.com you can
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos follow new rockstars and subscribe
to rockstar some more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you